samantha bonjour vous avez assisté à des
échanges entre journalistes et membres
du gouvernement que pouvez-vous nous
dire sur cette réunion alors le rhdp ne
c'est vrai nous a reçus ici au siège
donc du parti pour des échanges en off
c'est à dire qu'il n'était pas possible
de faire entrer les caméras et de films
et donc il a été question de la
situation post-électorale ici dans le
pays
le parti au pouvoir qui s'est très peu
attardé sur les arrestations présumé de
hauts cadres du pdci
selon le parti cette personne donc
serait interpellées pour troubles à
l'ordre public et complot contre
l'autorité de l'état
certaines d'entre elles auraient été
relâchées après interrogatoire
cela s'est passé donc ces arrestations
se sont déroulées lors de consultations
sur ce fameux vous savez gouvernement de
transition civile lancé par pascal affi
n'guessan et et l'ancien président
ivoirien henri konan-bédié du coup c'est
vrai que il a été question de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui devant la résidence de
l'ancien président mais le gouvernement
ne souhaite pas aujourd'hui évoquer la
question des interpellés elle affirme
que pour l'instant il ya une enquête en
cours dont pas de confirmation sur le
nombre de personnes arrêtées
en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est
qu'on sait que henri konan-bédié il est
bien chez lui donc lui n'a pas été
arrêté pascal affi n'guessan en revanche
est bien les policiers sont allés le
chercher chez lui et après un
interrogatoire il a pu être libéré chien
et sa montée à ces échanges se déroulent
dans un
film à de tension politique assez fort à
abidjan on l'a vu est-ce que vous pouvez
nous décrire un petit peu le climat
actuel aujourd'hui en côte d'ivoire
aujourd'hui
en fait tout le monde se demande ce qui
se passe devant la résidence de
plusieurs opposants qui serait temps
cercle est toujours par les forces de
l'ordre
ses opposants ce son assaut a dude us
pays un autre homme politique connu ici
en côte d'ivoire albert mabri toikeuse
il ya aussi le domicile de pascal affi
n'guessan et puis la résidence d'henri
konan bédié
ce matin nous sommes allés vérifier la
situation sur place effectivement le
périmètre de son domicile est
complètement bouquet bouclé par les
forces de l'ordre c'est impossible en
tout cas de rentrer les forces de
l'ordre qui nous ont demandé donc de
nous éloigner et la tension est extrême
dans ce quartier de cocody où d'ailleurs
nous avons été empêchés de réaliser un
duplex par des jeunes très en colère
très remonté qui nous ont donc empêché
de travailler ils ont tenté de de
dégonfler une des roues de notre
véhicule et puis au moment où nous avons
tout arrêter nous sommes partis et bien
ils ont ils m'ont arraché les feuilles
en fait les feuilles que j'avais dans
les mains donc cela témoigne en fait de
la situation très tendue dans certains
quartiers celui ci particulièrement dont
cocody à abidjan et dans ce climat de
tension politique et de bras de fer
entre l'opposition et le pouvoir il est
très difficile donc pour les
journalistes de travailler sereinement
un climat qui s'est durci depuis que les
forces de l'ordre se sont déployées hier
ils ont même dispersés à coup de gaz
lacrymogène des militants des
journalistes étaient présents sur place
puisque il a participé à une conférence
de presse
voilà pour la situation sur place
s'agissant justement des déclarations
aussi
de la france qui a fait une sortie jean
yves le drian donc appel à la retenue et
dans le cadre du droit constitutionnel
et bien et qui appelle aussi à la mise
qui a mis en garde face à des actes
d'intimidation et bien ici les autorités
ont réagi en précisant surtout que le
gouvernement français mettaient l'accent
justement sur le respect du droit
constitutionnel donc il est difficile
aujourd'hui de dire ce qui va vraiment
se passer ces prochains jours à abidjan
en tout cas rien ne devrait bouger
en ce qui concerne ce bras de fer est là
et la situation devant la résidence
d'henri konan bédié parce qu'on attend
que la cour constitutionnelle proclame
la victoire d'alassane ouattara
normalement cela doit intervenir cinq
jours avant sanou jours après la tenue
du scrutin dont qui s'est déroulée le 31
octobre dernier
on l'aura compris donc climat politique
et social assez tendue du côté d'abidjan
et la côte d'ivoire merci ça monte
ramsamy pour toutes ces précisions merci
également à claire nico derrière la
caméra